recording in progress
a couple of last things lined up and
waiting for
Dr predom Woodley are to join us
foreign
moment
while we're waiting I'll get the
presentation on the screen
and what you know my name is Stuart
Creek I am with simply learn I'm here
with Anna bargi also I've simply learned
we are the delivery partner
for I IIT Bangalore
for this program
we'll have Professor moodley are with us
shortly I hope
all right
you're starting soon
just check one more thing here
foreign
okay
let me um do a little bit of
introduction while we're waiting
we're going to be talking about the i i
t Bangalore program
on UI and ux Design
which will help you become a creator of
products of delight users
so we'll be talking a little bit about
UI and ux Design
we'll go over what the program offers
we'll talk about how the program gets
you job ready
for this field
we'll go over enrollment steps and we'll
handle your q a toward the end so if you
have questions for
Dr moodley are for onab or myself please
put them in the Q a function
we'll go back to our title slot is
honor was checking on Dr Woodley Art's
availability here
and Welcome to our live stream audience
as well
waiting for Dr moodley to arrive
d
hello hi Naman are you there
hi sword yes
we're waiting for Dr moodler
yes I have
[Music]
okay
just to reiterate for our LinkedIn
audience this is a preview of the
program uh from iiit Bangalore on UI and
ux Design
which will help you become a creator of
products that Delight users
it started shortly
foreign
can join us
so
um
yes
well we'll talk about what this program
offers yes go ahead
so uh we have launched this uh
in your way ux program in collaboration
Bangalore and this program specifically
is targeted at uh audience who are who
want to move into a design role into a
UI ux role and specifically design is
getting more and more prominence these
days with more and more companies
transforming themselves as software
companies and design is at the Forefront
of it even the specific uh
like interface and software which we are
using right now is also
designed by some designer
[Music]
thank you
um just a moment as I had a small
Network problem
and we're back
so Norman you were saying about UI and
ux design would you go ahead please
so uh
UI ux design like has always
shaped a lot of product firms a lot of
software firms it is always used and
very crucial for success of products
services and
various systems it is used by
forms across different Industries be it
product form BG directly Services form
digit consulting firms eat hardcore
manufacturing forms hardcore
let's say Hardware development firms and
we all knowledge intuitive interfaces
have always select users understand
information and control it in a simple
way
let even this let's say the software
we're using right now Zoom we have like
various buttons keywords a lot of
functionality a lot of experiences
delivered to us in one combined software
and UI is also a part of this whole
software as well
yeah and it's it's interesting to note
that um
unlike many years ago where uh software
was designed for the efficiency of the
company that was producing it to make
their processes more efficient
um software now is designed
for the convenience of the user and in
many cases for example
an app like Facebook
you don't get a software manual that
instructs you how to use the program
they rely on the idea that the user
interface and user experience are so
intuitive
that when they offer a new feature
you'll be able to pick it up immediately
this is why this is so critical to the
successive projects
so no man if you could go over the
parts of the job the UI and ux still
later does
so uh at a high level a job of a UI ux
designer is to first of all identify the
customer's core problem when let's say
we are trying to build a product with
the designer job is to first of all
identify the customer's core problem
what is that we are trying to solve
get a full Hands-On in-depth knowledge
of who is the exact customer how what
are the needs of the customer what
drives the customer what is the specific
customer looking for
and then you have to uh make sure that
you are building
uh customized usable experience for the
specific digital users and creating
those will always involve designing
flowcharts designing graphic designs
with taking care of the each and every
element which you see on your screen
there is a well-defined research process
uh hardcore testing goes into it and
then eventually a final product with a
intuitive
valuable and defined user experience
comes out making sure that uh
it is usable this is the core difference
between UI and ux a UI always makes a
product beautiful but a ux will make it
more usable which is why the con a lot
of user psychology is also involved in
terms of UI you have design you have to
understand the needs of the customer how
they think and make sure that a design
is equally usable and adding a lot of
value to the customer
um
let's move on there's a sample job
description this came off of
indeed and
this talks about the
particular requirements of the role you
can see that
um the job of the UI ux designer is to
work with development teams to create an
intuitive and enjoyable user experiences
and user interfaces and so the designer
is involved at all levels a product
Discovery in design and delivery
understanding and empathizing with the
customer
than working with the product owner to
develop a product Vision so
this is a role that
goes through the entire life cycle of
the product and you can see some of the
requirements here being able to use
research and data to guide
recommendations
prototyping presenting design Solutions
doing human-centered design working the
tools like figma and sketch
familiarity with uh
web coding HTML CSS JavaScript and
having a portfolio
important to include in your
resume for this job so
we're going to talk about how
this program is going to help you
qualify for jobs of this type in this
world and you
tell us a little bit more about these
phenomenon or July so
so when it comes to ux designer there
are different types of role variant
designers collaborate with different
product manager Engineers to eventually
build a product
it could be the role could call be
could be called a ux designer it is
sometimes it also called a UI designer
you can get into a web designer or
someone who is actually goes and design
core websites there could be a ux
researcher for example Adobe hires a lot
of ux researchers the job the job is to
identify and build new user experiences
new user interfaces
then there could be a UI developer there
could it could be a us developer as well
wherein a designer will also work in
collaboration with Engineers with
product managers to sometimes even
create new set of designs
I'm seeing like some questions coming up
on the panelist so yes if you are
existing designer this is a very strong
course for you to upskill even if you
are not from any design background you
are from any other background could be
engineering could be even sales could be
you are coming from a category role you
could be coming from a hardcore coding
role you can always move into a design
role with the help of this program
so I'd like to ask a question
and this question is what has stopped
our members of the audience
from enrolling in a program of this type
up until date
um if you are on a streaming service you
too or LinkedIn you can put A B C or D
into your chat or comment box
and I'll leave this open for another
10 seconds
and we'll close in three
two
one
oh
so the biggest objection in our audience
today is not finding a program that has
a comprehensive curriculum that covers
all the
kinds of skills tools that we've talked
about so far and then not being able to
get practical
experience that you can use to
demonstrate to a potential employer or
your current employer the new skills
you've acquired
and finding it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos and just a
self-taught mode but let's
show those to you
let's move on
and talk about this program
all right so
simply learn has tied up with triple it
Bangalore for to launch this Advanced
certification in UI ux design it will be
like duration is 5 months and I'll just
call out the core
features of the program so
in terms of curriculum this is a very
comprehensive curriculum designed
by making sure that the specific
components of the curriculum are exactly
what is need needed in the market we
have studies across different job
descriptions the demand in the industry
we work with corporates to build this
curriculum and it is very well aligned
with the needs of the industry each and
everything which will be taught in the
specific curriculum is the actual
Hands-On skills which we are teaching
you which will be directly used in your
future jobs
the course will have Capstone projects
which will help you eventually build a
portfolio so for everyone who is
enrolling in the program will eventually
create their own portfolio which can
which improves your chances of getting a
job so someone who is coming up with a
portfolio who has the design ready they
can showcase their work the probability
of getting a job increases by 50 for you
and we will also have faculties from
triple it
who have clearly vetted this curriculum
and they have uh clearly like gone
through the curriculum their feedback is
taken into account and then finally this
uh curriculum is designed there will be
expert instructors from Simply learn who
are already working in the industry who
are actual designers who have been doing
this for quite a few years they are
going to teach you in life virtual
classes and there will be interaction
with peers and the instructors and you
can most of you are already working so
you can also fit this into your
lifestyle and eventually this classes
and the sessions can happen over
weekdays where you can take out some
time upskill yourself and eventually
grow into a new role or upskill in your
existing role
foreign
at the end of the process you receive
your certificate issued by triple it
Bangalore
that
tests the fact that you have completed
the Core Curriculum successfully
produced a Capstone project that has met
the standards from the program you'll
have Hands-On learning with the
industry-based product of projects along
the way not just the one Capstone
um there will be live master classes
delivered not just by uh IIT triple it
back Bangalore faculty but also by top
design experts from the industry
including Amazon Adobe and Microsoft
these are working senior UI ux designers
um who will
give you the benefit of their experience
expertise in the industry and a part of
this program which phenomenon will
describe later is the simply learned job
assist career service
which will help you in your job search
once you've completed the program
so I just want to add one more thing
here so uh these live uh industry expert
sessions from Adobe Amazon Microsoft
these are existing designers who were uh
in your stage before few years and they
have gone through this whole process of
becoming a designer they have done it
themselves and these sessions will help
you get mentorship guidance how their
Journey has been
so that you can learn get guidance from
them learn from them and eventually
follow a similar path as they did and
eventually end up at top jobs in top fan
companies as well
if you can subscribe triple it Bangalore
to our audience yes so triple it
Bangalore was one of the first uh
tech school based out of Bangalore it
has been uh high focus in terms of
delivering quality education research
entrepreneurship and especially
Innovation they have a strong focus in
terms of innovation entrepreneurship and
also design they have identified as one
of the core
factors in terms of leading Innovation
which is why they were replied to me has
a strong uh interest and confidence in
the specific program
and even triple ITV has a strong brand
name when it comes to uh digital
technical design skills and a lot of
corporates across the industry a lot of
recruiters have widely widely accepted
Triple A to B as one of the like top
colleges in India
and they work uh closely with the
corporate sector to make sure that
they're training people to meet the
requirements of jobs in the new digital
economy so yes antiplier is also Rand uh
one in terms of technical education by
India today and also they have received
top one two three ranking from different
uh college ranking companies be it like
Forbes be it India today be it like
Times Higher Education
excellent
for this program you must meet certain
eligibility and prerequisites if you
could describe those for us uh Naman and
how strict they are yes so first of all
I want to call out
you need to have your bachelor's degree
with at least 50 percent of marks
minimum one year of experience
and you could be coming from any field
you could become uh from any field you
could be a aspiring designer you can
always take up this course even existing
designers who wish to upskill this
course is also open for them so there is
no entry barrier in terms of your
current role you could be in any role
you could be working across project
across design you could be working with
across coding sales development
manufacturing and you want to switch
your careers so this course is always
for you
excellent so we'll ask one more poll
question
of several
and with this poll question we're asking
um
sure I've got the red poll question
how much experience do you have we're
just curious to know in our audience
today
what the distribution is
and I'll close the poll in about five
seconds
here is the result I'll share that
so almost 60 percent of our audience are
folks who are still in their studies
um and the remaining 40 are people with
some experience in the workplace so
uh that 40 percent of the are the cohort
generally who are eligible
from the perspective of the one-year
minimum experience requirement
onto
how this program prepares you
so we talked about uh
a online learning environment and the
environment is
completely digital if you can describe
how the features of the online learning
environment works that would be great
well she would prefer me to do that
yeah so uh
in terms of the learning environment
simply learn has
its own learning management system which
is an online software where you will be
able to attend virtual classes there
will be tests you will be given Capstone
projects eventually building your
portfolio and once the whole program is
completed you will receive a final
certificate from triple it Bangalore the
in terms of uh our core learning
management system it is a very
sophisticated well established software
that we have been building over the past
10 years and it is very uh sophisticated
in terms of you'll have the features to
have peer learning managing your
curriculum get pre-reads you can even
collaborate with your partners
and eventually uh learning management
system which helps you
uh not to worry about any other
component in this today is like fully
digital world and focus primarily on
learning and improving your skill set
the learning management system lets you
see your entire program curriculum all
the core courses and electives uh keeps
track of your progress through them
gives you the calendar of live classes
provides the environment where you take
the live classes where you interact
directly with your instructors and peers
it also includes a
Community Forum where you can interact
with your fellow students ask them
questions
get Mutual support there's a 24x7
support desk that
simply learn operates to make sure that
you have the ability to ask questions
about how the platform works or about
the subject matter at any time because
we know you may be working on your
schoolwork
at any time during the week 24x7
according to your schedule
missed the video uh
you wait for just a moment I will bring
that up
apologies for the
confusion here
so uh
this this is these are all the core
modules which will be taught in the
curriculum it starts with user
experience design where you learn the
whole user design process all the the
life cycle the whole framework and then
you eventually tap into user interface
design principles
then talking about UI prototyping and
styling where you learn all the key
elements of a user interface including
like buttons including text including
colors including uh the whole interface
and then research testing and then
finally what all you have learned you'll
get the option you get a Capstone
project wherein you will have to
implement all of your learnings and
create a portfolio for yourself and this
put your portfolio will increase your
probability of getting calls from
recruiter probability of getting jobs
along with this
X core like expert faculties and
professors from triple ITV will come in
and deliver master classes
there will be industry expert sessions
from experts at design experts at Adobe
Microsoft
and Amazon and you will build some
design core websites from scratch and in
terms of elective we also offer a design
thinking uh
course as well which will help you
think about your user experience from in
terms of solving problems in terms of
adding a lot more value
you also will learn
to use various tools if you recall from
that example
job description that I put up a couple
of the tools that they've called for
figma and sketch which are very
important Tools in UI
ux design and
that
those tools Envision balsamic and more
are tools that you will use in the
projects and and labs for this program
and you'll be called on to use them all
in your Capstone project so at the end
of the program when you
see those on job descriptions and when
you put these in your resume you will
have the confidence to say I have used
these I'm familiar with them and here
are examples of how I've used them
this is really a great way to
prove your skill set and build up your
toolkit
and then we've talked about the Capstone
project but um
the key point of the Capstone project is
it's a three to four week process it's
the final module in the program and you
work under the mentorship of your
instructor who will make sure that you
clear any blockers or doubts they will
meet with you weekly make sure that you
are coming up with a solution to your
problem that will
meet the requirements of the program and
you get to choose your Capstone project
problem to solve from several different
domains so you'll be able to
pick a problem that interests you and
then work on that and create the
solution
entirely on your own
with the mentorship of your instructor
and be able to put that into your
portfolio to demonstrate to
current or future employer
what you are now capable of doing in UI
ux design not about right Norman have I
described it correctly
yes yes
our program advisors uh triple it
Bangalore include Professor sweetheart
professor prakash professor Woodley are
um all of whom are
very experienced and qualified in their
academic fields and
have also
um as you can see especially in
Professor prakasu's case a lot of
Industry experience he has created two
startup companies
and so you're going to get a
curriculum that is designed and
supervised by people with both
academic and
practical industrial experience so you
know that this is a program that is
tailored to the requirements of Industry
and here are some of the people
that have
presented in this program go ahead
yes so these are uh designers from the
industry Amazon Microsoft and Adobe who
are going to deliver
mentoring and Industry expert session
where you will get the option to network
with them you get the guidance from them
learn about their Journey how learn
about how UI ux is implemented within
Amazon Microsoft or adobe how they have
curated their
Journey their career and how they are
looking forward to design as a career
line
and what are the problems they have
themselves faced and may they could like
tell you about it wherein you will also
learn the kind of problems the kind of
obstacles which come in the way of
becoming a designer and how these people
overcame them and now they are working
at top spam companies so it is
basically you get advice from someone
who has already done it
always extremely valuable yes talk about
learner outcomes
um
and this is where we will describe to
you the job assistive service because at
the end of the process once you have
received your certificate
if you are going to be looking for a new
position
we can give you help in that regard so
Naman if you could describe some of
these yes so uh along with the program
you will get a subscription to Simply
learn job assist wherein you will get uh
3 access to export webinars and career
events with industry leaders where you
could get the opportunity to network
with them
wherein jobs are also posted you also
have the opportunity to network with
folks and specially recruiters to get
into jobs
this is this membership is in
association with IM jobs wherein you
will also get the opportunity to have uh
to become a premium member of I am jobs
portal which has a very wide employer
Network you will get access to Unique
jobs which are not available to free
customers which is only available for
premium paid customers and then you will
get guidance in terms of writing your
resume
there will be people who will assist you
in writing your resume making sure it uh
goes past the ATS tracking system and
you will also a person will mentor and
support you in terms of building the
best resume which typically takes one to
two weeks and then there will be to get
you prepared for the interview there
will be interview with a practitioner
SME who is expert in this field they
will interview you and prepare you based
on your resume and help you provide you
with continuous feedback so that you can
continuously improve yourself iterate
yourself and eventually get ready for
the final interview so this this is like
all the three pillars for of preparing
for interview getting access to jobs
which everyone does not get access to
help in in terms of writing your resume
rewriting it optimizing it with the
guidance from Top experts from IM jobs
and also one-on-one interview service
which will help you prepare for the
final job and that final interview
one of the things about the resume
rewrite service is the resumes now go
through automated tracking systems so
the first process your resume has to go
through is an AI bot that will match
match it up to job description
requirements and
the ability to write a resume that can
pass that filter and still be attractive
to a hiring manager when it lands on
their screen or desk
is a really
kind of an art form so this is extremely
valuable to you as is a one-on-one
interview prep for the different
levels of interviews that you're going
to encounter from technical interviews
to management and cultural fit
interviews
uh we talked about expert webinars and
simply learned runs a series of webinars
um that are
no cost they cover various topics about
career
building job search
care and feeding of your careers
building
kinds of personal skills and soft skills
that you need in your career
looking at the state of the art in
Industry sector and even as you can see
taking a one-hour short course
mini course a lesson on a particular
technical topic so we'll be covering
various different areas along the way
but this is an ongoing series it's
available to you for as long as you like
and again at no cost
So based on what we have described to
you so far
question is
uh are you interested in enrolling
this program with triple it Bangalore
leaving this open for another
10 seconds
close in three
two
one
and almost three quarters of our
audience are interested in enrolling in
the program which is great
so let's share with you the enrollment
process
steps are very straightforward
and then if you could describe this
sure so uh all you need to do is uh you
just need to submit an application on
our uh website or the URL of the program
can be posted on this chat window
you just need to go there and apply
uh your application will be reviewed and
someone from our accounts here from our
admissions teams will reach out to you
for taking the next export you just have
to go and apply
and as Norman said I'm putting into the
chat window now for you um the
email address to contact and learning
Consultants as well as the web address
for the program page so
that's available right now in the chat
window
the next cohort of classes starts 11
March
um there will be an induction or
introductory session before that but
the actual
live classes start on 11 March and the
course program cost is one lock twenty
nine thousand eight hundred
it's the full price of the course but it
can be financed over time
with zero cost financing for as little
as 4 309 rupee per month
yes so you just have to pay 4 300 nine
rupees per month that is all
uh he wants to begin the payment process
they're they're able to enroll and take
the classes correct as long as they're
uh engage
the correct moment
yes yes
so again for more assistance you can
either use the link that is in the chat
window uh to go to the program page but
you can also email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
so
question for those of you who are
interested in
program
how soon would you like to start are you
looking at joining the cohort that
starts with March classes are you
looking perhaps in April or May
would you be looking further down the
road
numbers are slowing down so I'll leave
this open for five seconds more
in the poll
so about 28 of the audience wants to
start either in March or soon thereafter
and the rest of you are looking
six months or more down the road
and we recommend it
for those of you looking further down
the road do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to get any of your final
questions answered and also to keep in
touch with us
to keep track of future cohorts
this point we'll do questions and
answers and I will
take this down so
talk to us directly
and I'm looking into
q a
let's see if I can find
questions I think you have access to
that uh the Q a
number so if you see questions you'd
like to address
going through
oh I'm just seeing where is the keyword
yeah I'm scrolling down through here
will we get a copy of this presentation
you will not get a PDF copy but you will
get a link to the uh recorded
session so you'll be able to review that
we'll be sending that out in email
uh in the next day or two
um
Rania asked a question for you Norma
does this require coding or what are the
prerequisites in terms of programming
knowledge for this course
no so you don't need any sort of
programming language you could be having
any background
and just match our eligibility criteria
in terms of having a graduation and one
year of experience
and you don't need to have any sort of
programming knowledge to take this up
got a question about the fees but I
think we already discussed those
one lock twenty nine thousand
and some odd
well like one lot twenty nine thousand
eight hundred
um
and also based on your profile and based
on your uh past background you will also
be eligible for some scholarships which
are admissions counselor counselors will
talk to you about once you apply
seems to be all of the questions that we
see here
College bets if you have questions in
our streaming audience I'm not seeing
them
at this point what do you think about
the Google ux course how would you
compare this
um Naman
this course is something like what the
Google what Google offers directly
so this this school
uh UI ux certification from triple it
Bangalore will provide you with a
certificate from uh esteemed University
triple it Bangalore which has a strong
Legacy and a strong base
you will and these will be delivered via
live lectures
which are not in that specific program
also uh
you will get strong guidance from uh
industry experts from Amazon Adobe
Microsoft
and you will eventually uh get helps in
terms of training yourself from
interviews you will get job assistance
you will get the coaching and training
in terms of preparing your resume
preparing your applying to jobs and
eventually finally get into a role
so these are the additional uh features
of this program
a lot more depth and
substance yes
um parties asks whether there are
options for
scholarships
does that apply yes there are options
for scholarship but that is entirely
based on your background and your
profile once you apply on the web page
our admissions counselor will reach out
to you they will evaluate your profile
and then you will be able to use it for
some scholarship
excellent
and that covers all oops sorry didn't
mean to scroll through that fast
um that covers all of our questions that
I've seen
so let's get to
the last part of our
I'm going to ask this last poll question
with this last poll question if you are
interested in receiving a proof of
attendance for this session today that
you've just attended
um answer yes here as well but this is
generally a question about do you need
help from our learning counselors
ask us at simplylearn.net
but again tick yes if you're interested
in getting the
proof of attendance certificate for day
today's session
we'll leave this open for another five
seconds
all right
about a third of you are interested in
getting live
consistent so please do contact us at
ask us simplylearn.net the QR code will
take you to the program page as well
but we do
thank you for being here I'm going to
put into the chat one last time the
um
program link
and the
email address
at your fingertips
we did have one question that came in
late about the timing of the live
classes uh Naman winter the live classes
held
so the live classes will be held on
weekends
from six to nine pm
on ISD excellent
so you don't have to
compromise with your existing work
schedule right
yeah all the other work that you do in
the course outside of the live classes
can be done on your own schedule at any
time during the rest of the week 24 7.
so
that's one of the great things about
this program and
thank you again I want to thank uh Naman
and Arnav for being here and we look
forward to welcoming you into the
Learning Community with triple it
Bangalore and simplyarn
that concludes our webinar for today
thank you